cet entrepôt du nord de montréal est une
véritable fourmilière
un contraste frappant avec la paralysie
qui touche tout le pays mais les
travailleurs font des portions de
nourriture qu'il place dans des boîtes
des repas prêts à cuisiner qui seront
livrés à domicile un service très en
demande par les temps qui courent
avec la crise du coronavirus c'est
certain que les gens veulent rester à la
maison veulent sortir le moins possible
il ya des gens qui sont à risque
mais c'est de satisfaire tous nos
clients et les clients avec nos vols à
la crise chaque semaine cocquyt livre
des boîtes comme celle ci à des milliers
de clients surtout au québec mais aussi
en ontario et dans les maritimes
depuis la semaine dernière les commandes
ont augmenté de plus de 50%
une croissance que l'entreprise
québécoise qualifie de phénoménal pour
cette semaine on essaie d'aller recruter
une certaine de nouvelles employées et
la même chose pour la semaine prochaine
avec 200 employés supplémentaires
l'effectif de l'entreprise doit doubler
et elle n'est pas la seule à demander de
l'aide
à montréal les fermes lufa qui livrent
des paniers d'aliments ont besoin de
main d'oeuvre de toute urgence
d'autres grands joueurs au pays comme le
blaze et dollarama se lance dans une
vague d'embauchés importante alors que
wal mart compte engager dix mille
personnes au canada et aux succursales
de la rivière on a besoin d'augmenter le
nombre d'effectifs qu on en annonce
kursaal dans certains cas pas aussi
répondre à l'absentéisme de certains
certains associent qu ici aussi des
employés choisissent de rester à la
maison
les patrons doivent rassurer les troupes
quant aux mesures d'hygiène
voyez autour de moi tous les employés
par des masques c'est pour pour les
entrevues supporte masse mais sinon j'ai
toute la journée ont toutes les
employées par des masques pour se
protéger eux mêmes et pour protéger
leurs collègues de travail des mesures
essentielles pour assurer ce service
devenu essentiel ici sébastien
desrosiers radio canada montréal